they make it their business to mind your
business
ron paul has been banned in d.c the
personalized license plate that is the
DMV's massive list of rejected plates
includes all kinds of saucy and random
sentiments you'll find religious
messages sweet thoughts that couldn't
possibly offend anyone and marijuana
references lots and lots of marijuana
references but this time the nanny the
month comes to us from Watertown New
York where the city has banned roommates
from residential neighborhoods this is
not a dirtbag thing that I'm trying to
drag my anniversary it all started when
Deborah Cavallaro complained to the City
Council about her next-door neighbor who
shares his home with his fiancee and two
friends oh I'm trying to do is just go
out there and have a normal life a quiet
life 27 year-old Travis Hartman
explained that he was just starting out
I needed some help paying the mortgage
on the home he recently bought he asked
how the city could stop boyfriends
girlfriends
domestic partners for soldiers from
buying a home and living together
Hartman will be grandfathered banned but
in a 3-2 vote the City Council zoned out
future roomies lost on the busybodies
was the ironic twist to something that
happened at the same neighborhood many
years ago I remember very well a
well-to-do neighbor who was upset very
much over a low-income couple moving
into a house close to her that couple
was mr. and mrs. Cavallari Oh check that
next month for more examples of
busybodies money um
what the irony not be lost if a neighbor
had her way 30 years ago over 80% of our
neighborhood would not be there today